The function we see over here on the left, is a line that is a slope of
negative one half. And its y intercept is negative 4. So, it's equation is
negative 1 half x minus 4. We can see that it starts here at x equals negative
5, and it goes all the way over to the Y axis or the f of x axis. The next part
of the graph isn't a straight line however, it's a Parabola. That's pretty
neat. And note that in order to use the notation we've been using for piecewise
functions, we have to rearrange the equation of each part of the function so
that f of x is by itself on the left hand side. If we do that for this
parabola, it's actually not too bad. It's just negative the quantity x minus 2
squared, since the vertex is at 2 comma 0. The graph is obeying this function
from 0 to 3. The last line we have has a slip of 1, and it's equation is just f
of x equals x minus 4. It's on the graph from 3 to 8.